[Musique]
les hôpitaux du pays fonctionnent
constamment fonteray urgence maison
familiale bloc opératoire ambulances les
systèmes de santé ils sont vastes ils
émettent des tonnes de gaz à effet de
serre en plus pollué le secteur de la
santé doit comme tous les autres
secteurs de l'économie faire sa part et
contribuer à l'effort de guerre dans la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
je m'appelle stéphanois suis
anesthésiste au centre hospitalier de
mort hier
que des le pétrin desrosiers chez
médecins de famille aussi le ch la gamme
maisonneuve en plus de partager l'amour
de la médecine les deux médecins
partagent un but commun verdir leur
réseau de la santé le système de santé
en commun et responsable aux 5 à 10%
de l'ensemble des déchets qui sont
générées par le système de santé qui en
soi ont une empreinte environnementale
acee halvick puis le canada à la covati
s'est engagé avec une cinquantaine de
pays à concevoir des systèmes de santé
résilient au changement climatique avec
de faibles émissions carbone on s'est
demandé où on en était sur le front de
la carboneutralité du système de santé
du québec
claudel pétrin desrosiers elle elle est
médecin de famille mais elle est aussi
président de l'association des médecins
du québec pour l'environnement et à la
contribué au lancement du réseau
d'action pour la santé durable au québec
bref elle est pas mal au courant du
dossier qu'est-ce qui fait actuellement
le réseau de la santé beaucoup de choses
un peu ici et là qui se font mais en
aucune mesure aucune stratégie lé
encadrants qui porte du ministère qui
dotent les cieux c'est les différents
établissements d'un plan et d'objectifs
francs l'heure est ce ça manque
cruellement de voulu savoir si le
ministre de la santé du québec avait un
plan pour rendre le système carboneutre
mais christian dubé a refusé de nous
accorder une entrevue on n'est pas dans
une situation où on a l'impression
comprends parfaitement la science
climatique puisqu'elle nous annonce
comme conséquence si les choses avancent
un peu c'est grâce à des initiatives du
personnel de la santé c'est entre autres
ce qu'on fait le docteur william de ses
collègues anastasis ton chemin il
s'intéresse depuis longtemps à l'impact
des gaz anesthésiant qu'ils utilisent
dans leurs pratiques ils ont décidé de
faire de sérieux changements dans leur
département du gard d'anesthésiques en
soit là c'est ce qu'une source
d'émissions très importante il ya
plusieurs technologies qui existent déjà
or il s'agit de les déployer on a la
chance d'avoir des nouvelles stations
d'anesthésiques et réduisent au maximum
la quantité de gaz qu'on donne aux
patients ont eu des agents de saisie qui
produisent beaucoup moins d'efforts on a
aussi les alternatives
le coût des gaz anesthésiant au chum est
passé d'environ 500 mille dollars un peu
plus de cent mille dollars par an grâce
à ces changements positifs la direction
du plus grand centre hospitalier de
québec le chum s'engage maintenant 20 la
carboneutralité nous avons pris
conscience de l'importance de ce sujet
et que nous nous sommes mobilisés et
nous allons nous mobiliser encore plus
dans les années qui viennent pour faire
comprendre à tout le monde la portance
de cette attitude c'est le dr williams
qui a le mandat de proposer un plan
concret pour que le chum atteignent la
carboneutralité pour donner les grandes
directions à tout l'établissement
il va commencer par faire un bilan de la
situation fois qu'on a ce bilan l'heure
on va rentrer à prendre des actions
concrètes un peu comme ce qui s'est fait
dans le département anesthésie ou
réduire son 100ème 80 et 95 pour cent
moins d'émissions
les deux médecins sont très inspirés par
ce qui se fait en grande bretagne ce qui
est très intéressant c'est que leur
système de santé aussi public et partage
beaucoup de similitudes avec celui du
québec ils ont établi une stratégie
nationale pour atteindre un système de
santé à zéro émission n'être qu'un
système de certains des 110 carbone
leurs deux objectifs le premier 2040
pour leur secteur à eux ce qu'ils
peuvent contrôler et 2046 pour
l'ensemble des chaînes
d'approvisionnement donc d'où viennent
leurs matériels d'où viennent leurs
médicaments et ils ont un plan pour y
arriver puis en fait après une première
année d'exercice ci ont atteint leur
objectif
l'urgence est réelle et les spécialistes
le disent on est plus à l'étape de
chercher des solutions mais plutôt de
les appliquer et de standardiser les
pratiques c'est vraiment une question de
volonté on sait que la crise climatique
c'est la menace numéro un à la santé du
21e siècle et on sait que la solution à
la crise climatique c'est d'arrêter
d'émettre des gaz à effet de serre si
dans le quotidien stein des gens qui je
sais à quel point la crise climatique va
affecter leur santé pour moi il ya un
devoir de cohérence que le système dans
lesquels je les accueille soit soit
aussi à l'air par rapport à ces
questions là puis face à perpignan par
l'exemplarité